what's going on guys this is rob and
let's talk about obi-wan kenobi episode
four honestly i really enjoyed this
episode and and here's the thing
i gotta say i i just wanna throw this
out there because when the show first
launched when it first came out the big
question everybody had and i was really
one of those people is what are we gonna
get the fight between obi-wan kenobi and
darth vader and in the last video that
we did we talked about at least my
thoughts on the fight between the two of
them how i viewed it and and whether or
not it was a good fight a bad fight what
it represented highlighted its
shortcomings different things like that
but what i want to kind of talk about
here is this kind of continuation bit of
a discussion on darth vader along with
the rest of the show because the reality
is once vader appeared in episode three
uh at least the third episode of obi-wan
kenobi it was kind of one of those
things where like the cat's out of the
bag right like we have to start seeing
more of darth vader otherwise fans will
be disappointed and i love the way they
handled that and i think that that's
really a larger discussion on how disney
has handled darth vader i know a lot of
people are on the fence and a lot of
people at least really really hardcore
star wars fans are very much just
disenchanted with disney's handling of
star wars at least in the in the movies
anyway a lot of people really enjoyed
rebels different things like that and
that's fair but
one thing that i think no one can deny
is how disney has handled darth vader
that no one can really take that away no
one could look at how disney's handled
darth vader and say yeah man they really
screw the pooch on that not at all right
and i think the best way to sum this up
it was actually a comment on a youtube
video that i saw which made the case
that disney had captured darth vader as
this almost larger-than-life imposing
dark figure right what made darth vader
so captivating when star wars first came
out and really just captured the
imaginations of people i would even go
as far as to say
until we got to episodes one two and
three really episode three more than
anything else was the mystery and
intrigue behind him we knew he had a
backstory but we never knew how he
became darth vader now granted episodes
one two and three is just a trilogy that
is really just the rise and fall of
anakin skywalker but as far as like when
vader became vader right so like the
black suit and the breathing and all
that kind of stuff it's iconic and that
as darth vader anakin was more imposing
than he was when he was just regular
anakin so it's like this force of nature
is kind of how you see darth vader when
he shows up things are really about to
pop off and so i think disney's handled
that perfectly and i think they've done
it great in obi-wan kenobi again my
thoughts on the whole fight and
everything in episode three was like
well i mean it was designed to highlight
just how far these two had fallen in
terms of power right darth vader is
nowhere near as powerful as he was as
anakin skywalker regarding his use of
the force and his lightsaber abilities
and so on and so forth and obi-wan
kenobi does not have the same connection
to the force that he used to right so
literally
just a couple of relatively old guys who
just aren't as powerful as they were
trying to recapture their prime
ob and darth are going through a midlife
crisis so the thing behind this and this
is this is what i think was really great
in this episode is that it didn't focus
so heavily on darth vader because there
is such a thing as overexposure right
like if if obi-wan kenobi had like one
part this story about riva basically
trying to prove her worth for whatever
reason that hasn't necessarily been
explained yet and then they bring darth
vader in episode three and suddenly it's
all about him then you lose the pacing
of the show like people are like is it
about riva or is it about obi-wan or is
it about darth vader is it about all
three like what's what's the whole deal
here i think that having darth vader
appear sporadically right like only
appearing at the very end of this
episode to basically chastise riva and
then almost kill her only for her to
realize or for her to tell us like i
essentially put a tracking device in
their ship i let them go that's why i
didn't destroy them kind of showing that
sort of espionage subterfuge element of
being an intelligent sith somebody that
differentiates themselves from like a
stormtrooper who shoots and can't even
do it accurately versus a high-ranking
sith who would actually think of that
right like let them go like let that
small fish go so they'll lead us to the
big fish and then we'll kill them all in
one fell swoop having him up here in
that capacity was great it was it was
great because what it does is it shows
like vader's here man like when it when
he shows up it's not one of those things
where it's like oh cool vader's here
listen enough that's awesome right it's
one of those oh damn dude vader's here
like literally he just comes walking in
like just pissed you can just tell by
the way he's walking which that's one of
the things i also want to talk about
here for a second one of the things that
i love the most i've
always loved about darth vader in the
absence of facial expressions because of
the mask on his face
everybody's always had to find other
ways to show to convey how he's feeling
and like through a combination of his
walking his breathing and the music
right the the kind of tone that they set
in the tv show itself you could tell he
was pissed man you could tell he was mad
as hell
and so when he came walking in this is
like oh damn dude this is rough right
and so it was like okay like this this i
mean she's obviously not gonna die here
they're not gonna kill off a character
like that in the fourth episode without
giving us any indication of what her
backstory is outside of when i was a
little girl leia things were taken from
me and that was basically it you know so
you knew she was going to survive i love
the way they handled that whole thing
now with everything else going on in the
show i still say
it's a bit lackluster right i do love
reva i think they're stretching out her
story a little too long i think this
episode when she was talking to leia was
the best time to give us her origin
story it was the best time to give us an
explanation of like her backstory and
why she's doing what she's doing i think
it would be kind of amazing if it turned
out she was a spy
if it turned out that like she was
working with the precursor to the rebel
alliance as we know it in episode four
feeding information to them different
things along those lines and then like
ultimately she's she's killed my guess
here is that the different leaks are
right she's going to turn coat she's
basically going to turn against the
empire she's going to end up siding with
the rebellion but it'll be one of those
things where like she turns back to the
light side momentarily and then dies you
know it'll be something along those
lines i don't really know i have no idea
how that's going to go i mean there's a
reason we haven't heard anything about
her in any of the star wars properties
that have come later on right episode 4
or any of that stuff rogue one or what
have you you would think that if she was
instrumental in the formation of the
rebel alliance
we would have heard about her before
this so obviously she's going to die at
the end of the show regardless of what
happens you know whether she becomes a
good guy bad guy or stays a bad guy or
whatever the case is the whole thing
with lamp again i still think it's a
pretty loose you know and kind of a
flimsy plot like here comes princess
leia getting herself in trouble yet
again you know the adventures of leia
you know i think that leia is an
interesting character i will say it kind
of surprised me that disney signed off
on the potential torture of a kid but if
you guys follow things like the fallen
order and stuff like that that's not new
to you right like those are guys who
aren't aware the empire man they got
problems dude like there's no limit to
the lengths they will go to to get the
information they want like literally in
fallen order you end up finding out
there's a point where like there's some
younglings who escaped coruscant who
weren't killed by anakin skywalker but
they were ultimately tortured by the
empire and turned to the dark side right
like the story of riva largely seems to
be the same way that she was most likely
a youngling that was captured by the
empire and turned and the reason why she
hates the jedi so much is because nobody
ever came to save her so she felt
abandoned by them or something along
those lines but whatever the case is
right like i'm i'm kind of shocked that
like they signed off on that on anything
like outside of a video game because
video games of this day and age you
expect to be violent you expect them to
be like not really hyper violent but to
have like some pretty adult themes but
when it comes to something like disney
plus and obi-wan kenobi while star wars
has not always been like the most
g-rated thing
you can make a credible argument that
star wars is pretty family friendly for
the most part i mean there's some darker
themes there and i wouldn't say that i
would have like my two-year-old or like
four-year-old watch star wars but like a
seven or eight year old sure and so when
you have something like that with like
princess leia potentially being tortured
it's like damn that's pretty rough one
of the things i do like about that
though is it does instill the fact that
leia's resolve right like her fortitude
didn't just come out of nowhere right it
wasn't just like she inherited padme's
personality and she was always kind of
like this and nothing bad ever happened
to her she just lived and somehow you
know some palatial estate you know out
there with the organa family and enjoyed
fine wines and and political
conversation that she can't relate to
even though she tries to appear to you
because she's not really part of the
people who are being oppressed there's
different things along those lines right
you know but the cool thing about this
is it's like no man this girl's kind of
been through some stuff right so so now
that it's actually it's giving us a
little bit more than like the adventures
of leia and who knows what trouble
she'll get into today you know like now
that we're moving beyond that and we're
getting into like some more serious
themes with her character i'm kind of
digging the development but i still say
like trying to get leia back home is
just kind of a flimsy plot for the for
the show that being said i can't really
hold it against against you know disney
for that it's not the worst thing ever
right it's just i mean how do you write
a compelling series about obi-wan kenobi
but i feel like at this point we're kind
of we're kind of looking more like the
general show as opposed to the episode
itself but that's one of the things that
i've kind of noticed that within each
episode you just kind of get highlight
moments right like a big thing happens
that's worth talking about and like
that's basically it beyond that it's
just kind of like some things take place
and maybe that's just due to the slow
going nature of the show maybe that's
due to the fact they just wanted to
craft it in a way where it's essentially
a slow burn
but the reality is
with the with obi-wan kenobi in and of
himself i really wouldn't expect any
less i mean this show this this this
episode right here one of the things
that i loved about it and i don't know
if it was just kind of me reading too
much into it or if it was somebody they
were kind of going in the direction of
but like when he's in that tunnel and
like they're surrounded by water on all
sides and like he's being shot at by the
different storm troopers and so on and
so forth i you know it looked like his
powers were kind of coming back to him
right like he was just sort of i
wouldn't say getting back to obi-wan
kenobi in like episode three right just
like this ridiculously op jedi master
right who where it would have just been
child's play
to deal with those storm troopers in a
tunnel right i mean like let's let's be
honest with ourselves if we're talking
about like episode not really episode
one episode one he was still kind of
figuring himself out but like episode
two or episode three obi-wan would have
rolled right through those guys and
wouldn't even thought anything about it
right he would have just been walking
away without the lightsaber behind his
back just blocking him detecting where
the laser beams are with the power of
the force and like that would have been
it right it literally just would have
been nothing at all i loved here that it
was almost kind of like it seemed like
his connection to the force was growing
stronger that it was returning to him
and that makes sense because he's been
using a little bit more of it as the
show goes on which is one of the things
that i really enjoyed about this it
wasn't really one of these things where
it was like okay so leia is in danger
let's tap into the full mind of the
force right it wasn't really anything
like that it was just it was a small
callbacks right like the little
communicator being left on the the
console right like a callback to luke
skywalker and all those guys you know
from episode four but in that instance
when he like basically uses the force to
trick the stormtroopers into believing
the sound's coming from somewhere else
small little things right small little
uses and it's kind of funny because it
feels like the star wars equivalent of
robert loggia from scarface right you
guys remember that movie when he was
talking to tony montana al pacino and
pacino was like i'm going to build the
biggest drug empire ever right robert
logia is like no the people who make it
in this business are the ones who stay
small that's how obi-wan kenobi really
seems to kind of function finding this
balance between completely cutting
himself off from the force but using the
force just using it in small subtle ways
just subtle enough that darth vader
wouldn't be like what was that oh my god
it's only one kenobi let's go get him
right versus putting himself in a
situation to where there is no escape
because he's not using the force and
he's inevitably going to die so i think
using small little things like that kind
of showing us this is how he becomes the
obi-wan kenobi that we're the most
familiar with from episode four or at
least those of us who started star wars
with episodes four five and six before
one two and three came out i think this
is a cool thing kind of giving us this
this more subtle approach to the force
as opposed to like grandiose displays of
it is it a good thing a bad thing i mean
i guess it's up to you but i think it's
a good thing in all honesty maybe it's
just me as the guy who got into star
wars as a little kid with episodes four
five and six and then i saw one two and
three when i was in high school when
they came out that for me
i kind of prefer the more subtle obi-wan
kenobi and in all honesty i kind of
prefer more subtle uses of the force it
is cool to see right like what is it
starkiller in the trailer for the force
unleashed when he like rips down an
entire star destroyer from the sky i
mean stuff like that's cool but like
huge grandiose displays of use of the
force easily overused and they were
easily overused in the in episodes one
two and three four five and six had
subtle stuff right subtle little things
the most grandiose display of the use of
the force that you really saw in
episodes four five and six was really
like yoda lifting the x-wing out of out
of the lake or out of the the swamp on
dagobah and then basically telling luke
skywalker uh you failed because you
don't believe in yourself home slice
that's why you don't get girls so it's
it's i prefer the more subtle approach
to things right i prefer the more subtle
approach to the use of the force having
said that overall this episode was cool
wasn't really bored there wasn't really
a time where i was like okay so like
when do we you know when are we going to
get to this thing i didn't find myself
fast forwarding i mean in episode three
i kind of did i'm not really going to
lie it was by the 10 second increment
like you guys know how it is on disney
place where you get like a 10 second
fast forward thing i was using that
right a couple times some of that was
because i'm just impatient and and it's
it's it is kind of a problem not gonna
lie
i swear to god my impatience is gonna be
my downfall one day i've been working on
it but i was like i really want to see
darth vader versus obi-wan don't lie you
felt the same way don't judge me but
nonetheless right it's just it's one of
those little things right it's just just
one of those things but the the episode
was great i gotta say with all of this
the character of riva this is this is
kind of a main focus for me
i was really enjoying her in the
beginning
she really is kind of wearing thin to a
degree that's why i say they really
should have given us her origin story to
kind of bring that interest back because
at the moment right now
she kind of seems like a screw-up right
she seems pretty inept as like an
inquisitor right obviously i mean i
think that's kind of the way her
character is supposed to be she's
reckless you know she gets carried away
she she basically leaps before she looks
that she is more in line with the
emotional side of what it means to be a
sith mind is the logical side that's
necessary in order to overcome somebody
with a level of patience of obi-wan
kenobi and so it to a degree when she's
like well i i put a tracking device on
their ship so we'll ultimately find them
it almost to a degree kind of felt like
the writer is being like oh god we're
making her look incompetent aren't we
okay
we need something to make her look like
she knows what she's doing anybody have
any ideas uh you know i don't know ever
put a tracking device right kind of like
a hand-wavy answer right have you put a
tracking device on the thing and say
that she meant to let them go the whole
time that's kind of how it feels to a
degree which is kind of disappointing
because i love the character of riva
having said that like maybe that'll
change right maybe that'll shift around
and we'll end up getting something a
little more interesting regarding her
character but again i haven't quite
given up hope i haven't given up faith
on the character of reba it's just one
of those things where it's like okay
where's this going you know that kind of
a thing so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later peace